so check it out when I was flying here
from Calgary bro so I didn't know what
to watch I downloaded a Takashi Miike
movie if you don't know Takashi Miike he
did some of my favorite movies Ichi the
Killer audition he's basically the
Japanese I'm Quentin Tarantino he's done
like a bunch like sixty movies this
guy's a beast wasn't he the same guy who
did that movie with a sex in the green
house yeah visitor queue mmm-hmm which
if you haven't seen visitor cute it's
unwatchable almost but it is on because
you don't know what's going on in it but
there's a scene in it where there's a
man who makes love to a corpse
it's a funniest thing you've ever seen
he's making love to a corpse and he's
basically saying in Japanese like oh my
god the miracle of life you know even in
death women get wet right so he starts
having sex with her more okay and then
he pulls his hand up and it's her [ __ ]
and he chose this [ __ ] in camera it's
really great great one of the great at
cinematic masterpieces movie the title
blade of the immortal and it's basically
based on an anime and it's about samurai
and in the beginning of the movie he
fights like 300 other samurai and he
kills all of them right but by the end
you know his hands chopped off
you know he's bludgeoned and he's got
like 50 like you know I mean stab wounds
he's about to die but he kills him last
guy and he falls to his death and then
this which appears out of nowhere and
she goes killing me kill me and she goes
I'm not gonna kill you and she opens up
his chest and she puts blood worms
inside him reaches know there's these
little worms they're called blood worms
and they go inside him and then they
heal all his wounds and stuff so he
can't ever die that's why I play the
immortal yeah and it's like um music
warrior Deadpool yeah but it's not he
still feels I wanna pain but he can't
die like this is a scene where he fights
another guy that's immortal too who has
blood worms and they're killing each
other and like at one point it just cuts
to like them fighting and then it cuts
to a scene where one's on top of the
other
but one of them has like a hundred store
sword sticking out of his body it's
really funny this movie is funny I
laughed out loud in the plane yeah and
another scene where he eats right he
drinks a lot of sake because he wants to
get his blood worms drunk drug because
because he says like they like to party
he tells us girl that and then they like
they've healed his wounds faster or
whatever but it's a really really weird
movie and I think what if you were
sleeping and then you had one eye open
and you saw kalila just putting worms in
your mouth blood worms well you hit
you'd have to open up a wound because
their blood worms aren't they go in your
blood she's cutting your belly well as
soon as she cuts my belly I'm out hey
[ __ ] [ __ ] what are you calling my
belly for I have to light blood worms
you know but um if you know I somehow I
had blood worms in my body I would be a
vigilante and I would like yeah yeah I
would like I don't have any samurai
skills so it like it's basically he
doesn't have he's not stronger for
having blood worms so basically I would
have to fight people with my own power
like my own strength it like if it's
George and it would take me probably
forever but he wouldn't be able to kill
me in eventually I would kill him so
just out of like sheer stamina and being
able to regenerate yeah and I'd be like
and also another thing is that I would
I'd wear an outfit but I have to work
out because if I don't like wear an
outfit yeah if I weren't outfit the
people who will be able to recognize my
body because I have like you know me a
weird shaped body and people were like
oh no that's you know instead of going
Luda that there's a that's that's mochi
the Nugget
that's Bobby Lee no mochi the Nugget
that's my name
mochi then oh yeah see how that played
do you know that they actually see how
that plays yeah mochi or moshi moshi the
Nugget moshi the Nugget you know that
they actually used like maggots in the
hospitals and stuff to heal wounds yeah
in your land oh okay you guys we don't
do that
[ __ ] Cedar sinai you guys didn't
believe me when I said that they
actually have like poop pills to like
repopulate your gut biome and your gut
back to you but they're not really poopa
there's like elemental pills they're
straight up poop pills oh don't ever
yell poop pills at me like that I've
never seen that well they use maggots to
eat away all like the dead skin and
stuff if something is like let's say for
instance like you know gangrenous or
something like that it eats away at the
dead skin day yeah what do we like what
do you like civilized white people do
they use this in hospitals they use poop
pills there too yeah insects are crucial
to any type of like even even for like
forensic entomology to figure out when a
body how long a body has been dead based
on the maggots like life the stage at
which it has grown yeah let's say for
instance if they look inside your body
your corpse and let's they they inspect
the maggot and they say hey this maggot
is only four days old they'll be able to
determine how long your body has been
deceased exactly to the hour I have a
question for you yeah I always thought
this like when I saw like Gilligan's the
islands as a kid yeah I always thought
like you know what would I do if I was
it could and I thought could you eat
your own poop and if you did eat your
own poop a couple of days what comes out
of you more poop don't or something yeah
what kind of poop comes out I mean no
they're not making people [ __ ] eat
like a parfait of their own shape I'm
just saying I'm curious it's toxic you
would die because other things like
e.coli are coming out of your butt what
you came from within me what happened
yeah but you also have things that are
pathogenic
even in your gut we don't know that I
don't know that I'm sorry that I won't
eat my own poo even
[Laughter]
[Music]